Borrar el nombre de Wagner de la
existencia el sábado se retiró todo
rastro del Grupo Mercenario de su
antiguo cuartel general en San
Petersburgo Esta es una imagen del
edificio de hace una semana cubierto de
insignias de Wagner Este es el mismo
edificio una semana después Un día
después de que el organismo de control
de las telecomunicaciones rusas
bloqueara los sitios web del grupo
Patriot fundado por el líder de Wagner
Jenny una respuesta del kremlin a un
golpe de estado fallido en el que el
Grupo Mercenario marchó hacia Moscú
llegaron a 200 kilómetros de la capital
antes de dar media vuelta como parte de
un acuerdo que les ofrecía refugio en la
vecina belarus un acuerdo negociado por
el presidente Alexander lucashenko quien
en su discurso del viernes destacó las
ventajas de tener al grupo Mercenario en
su país
si fuera posible invitar aquí a
combatientes de Wagner Sería bueno para
nuestro ejército son las personas más
preparadas no son una amenaza para
nosotros son personas que han tenido
experiencia en el ejército y en la
guerra
son personas que lucharon en todo el
mundo por una civilización normal
occidente los odia hasta la médula según
un portavoz de las fuerzas fronterizas
de Ucrania hasta 8.000 combatientes
Wagner pueden estar desplegados en
velarus una cifra que aún no ha sido
verificada imágenes de satélite parecen
mostrar una base militar recién
construida en una ciudad a 230
kilómetros al norte de la frontera
ucraniana muchos sugieren que se
utilizará para alojar tropas de Wagner y
el líder del grupo jin este hombre de 62
años apenas ha sido visto desde su
exilio de hecho este vídeo del 24 de
junio es la última vez que apareció en
las redes sociales los informes apuntan
a que se encuentran refugiado en un
hotel de Minsk la capital de belarus